let's get some practice simplifying
radical expressions that involve
variables so let's say I have two times
the square root of 7x times 3 times the
square root of 14 x squared pause the
video and see if you can simplify taking
any perfect squares out of multiplying
and then taking any perfect squares out
of the radical sign well let's first
just multiply to this thing so we can
change the order of multiplication this
is going to be the same thing as 2 times
3 times the square root of 7 x times the
square root of 14 x squared and so this
is going to be equal to 6 times and then
the product of two radicals you could
view that as the square root of the
product so 6 times the square root of
and I'll actually I'll just leave it
like this 7 times X and then let me
actually factor 1414 is 2 times 7 times
x squared and actually let me let me
extend my radical sign a little bit all
right and the reason why I didn't
multiply it out obviously we could have
multiplied in our head x times x squared
is X to the third and we could have said
all right 7 times 14 is what 98 we could
have done that but when you're trying to
factor out perfect squares it's actually
easier if it's in this factored form
here especially because from a variable
point of view you could view this as a
perfect square already and then 14 is
not a perfect square
7 isn't a perfect square but 7 times 7
is 7 times 7 is a perfect square that is
49 of course so let's rewrite this a
little bit to see what we can do this is
going to be 6 times and I could write it
like this the square root of and let's
put all the perfect squares first so 7
times 7 that is 49 that's those
two x-squared 49 x squared and then I
could once again separate the two
radicals right over here so whatever
else is left
so I've already used the 707 the x
squared I have a 2x left times 2x
hopefully appreciate that these two
things are equivalent I could have put
one big radical sign over 49 x squared
times 2x which should have been exactly
what you have there but if you're taking
the radical of the product of things
that's the same thing as the product of
the radicals this comes straight out of
our exponent properties but what's
valuable about this is we now see this
is 6 times now we could take the square
root of 49 x squared that's going to be
7 X square root of 49 is 7 square root
of x squared is going to be X and then
we multiply that times the square root
of 2x times the square root of 2x and so
now we're in the homestretch 6 times 7
is 42 x times the square root of 2x and
the key thing to appreciate is I keep
using this property that a radical of
products or the square root of products
is the same thing as the product of the
square roots so even this step that I
did here if you wanted you could have
had an intermediary step you could have
said that the square root of 49 x
squared is the same thing as square root
of 49 times the square root of x squared
which would get us square root of 49 is
7 square root of x squared is X right
over there let's do let's do another one
of these so let's say I have square root
of 2a times the square root of 14 a to
the third times the square root of 5a so
like always pause this video and see if
you can simplify this on your own
multiply them and then take all the
perfect squares out of the radical so
let's multiply first so this is going to
be the same thing as the square root of
let's see 2 times 14
times five so let me actually just I'm
just going to two and five our prime 14
I can factor it as two times seven so
this is going to be two times instead of
fourteen I'm going to write two times
seven and then times five and then we
have a times a to the third times a well
actually let me just write that as a to
the fifth we have a to the first times e
to the third times e to the first add X
once you get a to the fifth
now what perfect squares do we have here
well we already see a perfect square in
terms of two times two and then a to the
fifth isn't a perfect square if you
think in terms of the variable a but you
could view that as a perfect square a to
the fourth times a so let's rearrange
this a little bit and so this is going
to be equal to the square root of let me
put my perfect squares out front the
square root of four two times two times
a to the fourth and then let me put mine
on perfect squares
times I have a seven a five and an A
that I haven't used yet so seven times
five is thirty-five so it's 35 a and now
just like we said before we could let me
do it we could say hey look this is the
same thing as the square root of four
times the square root of a to the fourth
just using exponent properties and then
times the square root of 35 a now
principal root of four is positive two
you could view this as a positive square
root and then square root of a to the
fourth the principal root is going to be
a squared and then we're going to have
that times the square root of 35 a and
we're done
let's do one more example and this time
we're going to involve two variables
which as you'll see isn't that much more
complicated so let's simplify the square
root of 72 X to the third Z to the third
so the keya can we factor 72 is not a
perfect square but kit is there a
perfect square someplace in there and
you immediately see that if you try to
factor it you get it you get
thirty-six times two and 36 of course is
a perfect square and likewise X to the
third and D two-thirds are not each
perfect squares but they each have an x
squared and Z squared in them so let me
rewrite this this is the same thing this
is the same thing as I can write well we
put all my perfect squares out front so
I have 36 36 I'm gonna take an x squared
out x squared I'm going to take a Z
squared out Z squared and then what
we're left with is we took a 36 out so
we're left with a 2 times 2 and if we
took an x squared out of this we're left
with just an X X to the third divided by
x squared is X to X and then Z to the
third divided by Z squared is just Z and
you can verify this multiply this all
out you should be getting you should be
getting exactly what we have here I do
that aligned on the Z to differentiate
so it doesn't look like my twos 36 times
2 is 72 x squared times X is X to the
3rd Z squared times Z is Z to the third
but now this is pretty straightforward
to factor because let's let me just I'll
do more steps and you would probably do
if you're doing it on your own but
that's because the whole point here is
to learn so 2x Z so that's just using
exponent properties and so everything
here is a perfect square this is going
to be the square root of 36 times the
square root of x squared times the
square root of Z squared which is going
to be square root of 36 is principal
root of 36 is 6 principal root of x
squared is X principal root of Z squared
is Z and we're going to multiply that
times square root of 2 X Z and we are
done